i'm trying to like make it so women just  like understand a little bit of like  just to sympathize it's like we're we're  like sport fishermen that's what i'm  saying  men like to fish  and sport fishing is different from  catching  fish for food you just get it you get it  you catch it and you you know you you  show your friends  you take a couple of pictures so you can  show people to fish  that you have the ability to catch  and then you release it back into the  water  but a lot of women in here you have  boyfriends or husbands  you were fish that jumped back on the  boat  and just was like flapping looking at me  like  hi  i was wondering if you're going to be  fishing here again next week like  yeah for other fish get off my boat  is that how you treat all the fish you  be like oh god damn